when a player engages with a game like
ours one of the primary goals from a
development and design standpoint is to
let them play improvisationally the way
that we are low for so much playoff
freedom to play your way philosophy as
we like to call it is that game
inevitably here hybrid because you allow
the play after doing whatever he wants
he needs to be able to sneak he used to
be able to fight he needs to be able to
steal to look through keyholes climb
anything the player can imagine I try to
give the player enough flexible verbs
basically and whenever possible we give
them non-combat actions that just let
them play at their own pace it's not
just about going left right over the top
of the building or possessing a fish and
swimming along in the river all those
crazy things you can do are using combat
or stealth or being very violent or not
killing anyone it's not just about that
it's just a moment-to-moment the feeling
of when something happens as a direct
result of your actions it's you
experience for instance we see player
arriving in front of a firing squad in
the street and some of them just walk
right past it some other people are like
is there loot to steal and some other
people approach it like morally hey what
did these people do exactly I think I'm
gonna defend them
we are already attached to a character
because we meet them in a lot of
situations we attached a lot of
attention to create characters that feel
real and from this if you dishonored to
is not just about the depth of the world
in the atmosphere the setting it's
really a stealth game compliance is
mandatory you can either use the stealth
a little bit to like sneak up on
somebody and take them out or you can
try to play the game without anyone
seeing you at all
clearly stealth is a key pillar of DS
Arnott and it's still of course keep it
out of this for instance shadow walk you
can take this like shadowy key form and
use it as a stealth power but it can
also be used to kill people we've added
many more non-lethal options as well
drop assassination was very popular
before but now you can land and knock
them out we've added a combat choke that
allows you not only to like break out of
combat and non-lethal II seduce somebody
but you can also use it to drag them
around use them as a human shield throw
them at an enemy so there's just many
more options just in the basics of
combat and subdued war I'm not sure I'd
call it mercy if you just want the
cathartic experience of chopping dudes
heads off and shooting them in the chest
you know dropping on them from the top
of the building taking out as many
corrupt guards and aristocratic weasels
as you want this honor can definitely be
approached that way when it's honored
one we had the outsider mark you giving
you supernatural powers the outsider
offers you his mark this time of
dishonor - you could say no
I never asked for your help and I don't
need it now what does it mean for you it
means that you won't have any power
throughout the game and for Earth level
designer it means that you should be
able to do everything that the other
guys could do with the powers sometimes
it's more difficult but at the end of
the day you can finish the game without
any power
it might sound pretty come to intuitive
as a designer you build almost like fun
original sometimes very complicated to
actually implement systems then you
include in your game an option - you
know lock them away why whatever you're
offering I can make my own way that's I
think because we are confident that of
core gameplay is interesting enough and
we are confident that the play of Meg's
that choice wants that kind of
experience he wants to be a human being
among human beings and feel like he's
the best he wants to be Batman and of
Superman we have players who play for
the story we have players to play
because they have stealth simulation
because I think Emily's cool or Kouros
cool some players move through the game
like a shadow without leaving anyone
disturbed and other players
a big trail of blood funny